sixto tonight makes his sixth major
league start this is the first time
he'll face an opponent for the second
time so
that adds a little bit of an extra
element of intrigue to this one
if you go back to his debut against the
nationals really of the
five starts he's made it was the
shakiest he allowed three runs
over five innings in that game he's
allowed three runs
in 27 innings in the four starts since
two ground ball outs here for sixto in
this first
inning pop-up and rojas calls for this
shallow left over toward the line makes
the play in a nice quick
easy efficient first inning for sixto
sanchez
eric fetty two starts career against the
marlins 1-0 with a 193
yeah 27 years old 6-4 195 last start on
the 11th against the braves received the
no decision gave up a couple of runs on
six hits
and five innings of work struck out five
walk four
so a man in scoring position for matt
joyce here's the pitch
swag on hit high in the air to right
center field playable to the big park
stevenson back out of the warning track
now he's there
and he one hands it midway on the
warning track to retire the side
for the marlins no runs and no hits an
error two steals and a man left at third
of the end of it
so the dh is a boy here's the catcher
john gold
grounded past anderson there was enough
of an opening and it was pulled through
there by gomes
digging for third is thames throw to
third he's out at third base thames
trying to get to
third and dickerson didn't have a lot on
it but it was accurate enough for annie
to apply the tag
so one out runner at second and he
drives the ball
off the end of the bat into the gap in
left center coming around to score is
gomes and it's
one to nothing nationals on a two-base
hit into left-center
by luis garcia and so a runner at second
one out of run home and carter ki
boom the batter swinging a ground ball
fair base in pass angle on the first
baseman
rounding third garcia coming home joyce
up with the ball he will make the throw
into second
it's a single to ride an rbi for kibum
his ninth of the year
and the nationals lead here in the
second inning two to nothing
eric fetty will face the 22 year old
rookie's second baseman
jazz chisholm it's two nothing nationals
bottom of the third
outside in a five pitch walk to begin
the marlins third inning the left
fielder corey dickerson who reached out
an error his first time up delayed steal
on a strike to throw down by gomes the
tag by turner is in time for the out a
diving tag for turner
catches chisholm stealing and that's the
second out of the inning you want to
play by turner on the tag
with a delayed steal attempt to walk
towards the bases first walk allowed by
six though in this game
so now stevenson just up today and a
swing and a ground ball base hit right
field
headed home is gomes garcia is headed to
the plate as well the throw home is way
off line
the sweep tag is missed and garcia goes
tumbling into the plate and the other
runners move up
stevenson's first hit in the big leagues
this year first two rbis
and the nationals now lead at four to
nothing now with the infield in victor
robles the batter
swinging a looping line drive base hit
over the drawn in infield
headed home is key boom stevenson will
stop at third and the line keeps moving
on the rbi single for victor robles and
the score now the nationals five and the
marlins nothing
for whatever reason betty seems to lock
in against this
marlins squad he's done it throughout
his career he's doing it again tonight
urgency is starting to pick up here for
the marlins and he paints the outside
corner with a tailing fastball at 95.
and eric fetty has strikeout number
three two two swinging a miss and a
tailing fastball down and away and
fetty has picked up a couple of
strikeouts in the inning giving him four
eric fetty just 57 pitches so far 35
strikes he struck out four marlins the
slider's been nice
he's had command of the two-seam
fastball wherever he wants it in
out but mostly down just moving it from
side to side so
real nice so far two down jorge alfaro
the catcher
swinging a ground ball left side slowly
hit keyboard cuts in front of turner a
long underhand shovel toss to garcia for
the out
and so the side retired fetty works
around the lead off walk no hits
ball one no strikes to andrew stevenson
just up today to rejoin the
nationals here's the pitch to the left
hand hitter and he
hits a line drive caught neatly by
aguilar
diving to his right good play from the
first baseman jesus aguilar the marlins
have a base runner with two down
matt joyce so bad and that was a miss
john gomez just dropped it so the
inning's over he tags out the batter
and eric fetty six of his best innings
ever as a washington national
a one hitter there he is will harris
16th game
13 innings 16 k's
two pitches cutter in the curveball cut
her in the
upper 80s low 90s and then that's a
strike away
and that takes care of that
approximately two hours and 15 minutes
for the nats and eric fetty to shut out
the miami marlins
five nothing on a two-hitter